tell us about the review what did you
find well over the last 14 months i've
spoken to thousands of people that have
grown up in and lived in and around the
children's social care system so
children
young adults who grew up in care parents
grandparents
and the big message from all of those
conversations is that we have a system
at the moment that's too crisis-driven
so it responds too late
and that when children do come into care
often that process breaks rather than
builds the loving relationships that
every child needs to grow up
successfully so that's what we need to
do
we need a big reset we need an
investment
program we need reform
over five years we're calling for 2.6
billion pounds to be injected into the
system where's that going to come from
well the um the issue is if we don't um
actually bring about some major change
in the system we'll be on track to have
a hundred thousand children in care by
2032 and that will cost us 15 billion
pounds a year so the choice for the
government here and for all of us
frankly is do we keep pouring money into
a system that's faltering and letting
down too many of the most vulnerable
and it will get worse and and more
expensive or do we actually take some
bold action now smart and invest
and change that so what would that
action look like
one of the major changes that we're
recommending is the creation of a family
help system where in schools and family
hubs and community settings we'd have
many more mixed groups of professionals
getting alongside families when they've
got an addiction or they're in a violent
relationship or have a mental health
issue
that's missing in the current system so
putting the resources into children's
social care to do that to get alongside
families in a low stigma way and help
bring about change for families that
should reduce the number of children
that end up needing to go into care
because we've not supported families and
then when we do need care and we will
always need a really strong care system
for children we actually put lifelong
loving relationships around them so that
they've got those connections for life
how do we compare in the uk to other
parts of the world well we've got a
system which um is often not very good
at making effective use of family
networks so grandparents or aunts and
uncles could play a bigger role in
children's lives people move away don't
they
people move away yes they move away so
they don't have the nuclear family that
they might have had you know 60s
certainly but what we've seen in the
review and this is through lots of
conversations with grandparents and
aunts and uncles is often really
torturous choices they need to make
between
getting financial support to become a
special
to become a carer for that child by
becoming a foster carer
but losing parental responsibility in
the child going into care or the
relative becoming a special guardian and
then not getting any financial support
and these are often grandparents who are
right on the bread line you know they've
not got a huge amount of money they are
prepared to step in and support their
relatives to grow up and the evidence
shows that that can be much better for
children's outcomes so we aren't doing
anywhere near enough on that at the
moment and what sort of age groups of
children are we talking about well we've
looked at the whole system so zero to 18
and um we've seen recently a huge
increase in the number of teenagers
coming into care it's a particular focus
in the room
one of the things we think is going on
is that harms outside of the home you
know we've built a child protection
system that's focused on abuse or
neglect inside the family home actually
we're seeing you know the growth of
things like county lines um some of the
exploitation yeah exactly some of the
exploitation in the community that's
driving up some of the need for the care
system and we've got a care system which
wasn't actually designed a lot of the
time for those teenagers and does it
break down into ethnic groups it does
we've seen real racial disparities in
the system about the amount of help that
black and mixed heritage
families get early on is much lower but
they come into the system
with concerns
later and much more rapidly and that's
new research that we're publishing today
and
is a real concern about you know how the
system understands different communities
is actually able to get alongside
families
and provide that support at the right
time good to talk to you thanks very
much indeed joining us much appreciated